(laughing)
- Hi guys, I'm Avi and
I love one-liner jokes.
Here's one that I came up with:
I know I should love myself
before I love anyone else,
but me and myself are seeing
other people right now.
(laugh track laughter)
I thought I'd challenge my friends
to come up with one-liners in 24 hours.
- I feel like I can tell
if something's funny
but I'm personally not funny.
I don't think anyone thinks
"Kane, he's hilarious."
- I think I can be funny when
I'm not supposed to be funny
but if somebody asks me to tell a joke
or I'm supposed to make people laugh
then it just all collapses and I fail.
- I'm hoping to write one funny joke
and just remember that for
the rest of my life today.
- There has to be a science to this.
- Hi, I'm Doctor Sal
Attardo, I'm a linguist.
And I specialize in the
linguistics of humor.
There is something called
the Principle of Cooperation
and basically the idea is
that when you communicate,
you're following some rules.
All jokes have to violate in some aspect,
the Principle of Cooperation.
Take for example, the
joke by Dmitri Martin.
- I think the worst time
to have a heart attack
is during a game of charades.
(laughter)
- When you reach the word "charades",
you realize that in fact, the
speaker wasn't cooperating.
When you get that, you get
one of the basic foundations of humor.
- To help Kane and Fernando, I brought in
a stand up comedy teacher.
- All right.
- Come on in.
- Okay.
There is no the way to do it.
Don't try to be funny.
Try to be honest.
Have it come from some place in you.
All right guys, that's our class.
- Wait, is this the whole lesson?
Wait, what.
(clock ticking)
This is so much harder
than I thought it'd be.
- I have one and a half jokes.
- So I'm about to test the jokes
for the very first time on Juan.
I used to be embarrassed about
how my boyfriend and I
met, but then I realized--
- All right, I'm done.
- But then I realized
some people get used to
(laughing)
- I'm the one who's supposed
to be laughing here.
- I can't believe I'm the person
that starts laughing
before I can finish a joke.
- I was trying to write these jokes.
I needed five, but I could only come up
with one and a half.
- [Fernando] Okay guys, so just please
be gentle, I have one joke.
So you know how I'm like a
Mexican immigrant, right?
Something that's really been bugging me
for a while is that
Donald Trump was saying
that we are rapists and we are criminals
and we're here to steal people's jobs.
The job he probably
thinks we're getting is
joining the Republican Party
and running for Congress.
- (laughing) Wait, no.
(laughing)
- [Fernando] Get it?
Okay.
- I didn't get it until the last second,
I was like "Oh, oh."
- I don't know, I would
give it like a six.
- Verbal validation from Asian parents
is like being constipated.
It takes blood, sweat, and tears just
to get the little bit out.
- (laughs) It's so true.
- I used to be embarrassed to say
my boyfriend and I met online,
but hey, sometimes you get furniture
off Craigslist, sometimes
you get a boyfriend.
- Yeah.
- Nah.
- That's a no go.
(laughing)
- So I finished all the one-liners
and told all the people.
I got a lot of silent
stares and confusion.
But you know, that's okay.
Not everyone can do what I did in a day.
- I think if anything, this made me
understand how difficult it
is to consciously be funny.
- Even though I got a
lot of awkward silences,
I almost didn't care
because I was just proud
that I was able to go
through with it and perform.